finally
441 days after the cdc implemented a
federal mass mandate for public
transportation
a federal judge has struck down the
stupid rule which was set to expire
yesterday before the bureaucrats decided
to extend it for another two weeks two
weeks where have we heard that one
before district court judge catherine
kimball mizell
ruled that the extended mandate quote
exceeded the cdc's statutory authority
improperly invoked the good cause
exception to notice and comment rule
making and failed to adequately explain
its decisions i actually got a text from
a friend of mine when this came out he
was 30 000 feet traveling on a flight
and he said wow you're not going to
believe it the captain just came over
the loudspeaker and said that the mask
rule is no longer in effect and almost
everyone took their masks off other
people got videos of this happening on
flights around the country take a listen
the bible administration announced that
the transportation security
administration will no longer enforce
the federal mandate
requiring mass in all u.s airports and
onboard aircraft
[Applause]
finally effective immediately
immediately mass are optional for all
airport employees crew members and
customers inside us airports and on
board aircraft effective immediately and
everybody is very very excited about
this because this judge found that the
good clause exception did not hold here
the good clause exception is a provision
of the administrative procedures act
that allows d.c bureaucrats to break the
rules for rulemaking when compliance
would be quote impracticable unnecessary
or contrary to the public interest so if
an emergency required an agency to act
with haste
it would be permitted to cut corners
but we're more than a year and a half
into this nonsense if there ever was an
emergency that permitted this kind of
power grab we are certainly long past it
this is great news as you can see the
people are so excited there in that
video on the flight i've got a flight on
thursday to boston i'm giving a speech
at boston university i look forward to
testing the rule perhaps i can become
the rosa parks of airplane muzzles
but
the ruling is bittersweet if all those
people on that airplane were so happy to
take the mask off
as we know that they are as we know that
we all were when we were flying around
and taking public transportation
why didn't we just all do it why did it
take 441 days it is a bittersweet moment
because it shows us just how far our
country has fallen it shows us just how
much the ruling class our crooked ruling
class is taken from us
we are 109 weeks into two weeks to slow
the spread and we're celebrating that
our rulers might now finally allow us to
breathe again
glad you liked that clip now please
ring the bell subscribe get all the
notifications check out i got this great
new video where we were at washburn
university and i actually ended up
sitting down with the gal who organized
a protest against me really really
surprising exchange go check it out
we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you